hey guys how's it going what's up man
hey so no i got a pretty interesting
story from back when i was in middle
school about time i was in seventh grade
about 14
there was uh this girl i knew and she
was in one of my classes and she
actually played xbox with us and
knew some of our other friends
and
when
we uh one day one night she sent out
this
message on xbox live to like all of her
friends saying
basically all doom and gloom saying
basically sounding like she was going to
kill herself and
being even at 14 i was smart enough to
see a red flag
and i called my dad over and he's like
and i was like what do you make of this
and he was like yep this seems like a
bad situation
you shouldn't really talk to this person
and
fast forward about i'd say about two
months
down the road
this girl she uh i found out she liked
me
so
this kind of leads into
i
and when finding this out i was just
like hey this is going to be
kind of cool i'll have a girlfriend
seventh grade whatever kind of silly i
look back on now
but this is where i start to like
complicate my life and justify why
i uh proceed to like try and convince my
dad after showing him that message
uh saying like oh she's getting therapy
everything will work out and
and yeah and i i unfortunately got
really devoted into it even though i
really didn't have anything like i
didn't wasn't like crazy into this girl
or whatever it's seventh grade
so then
leading up to that uh my dad basically
just metaphorically smacked me upside
the head one day sits me down and is
like
i don't i don't mind you having a
girlfriend but
how can you expect someone who can't
take care of herself to take care of you
you know what man you actually have a
great father
yeah no i know yep you guys would get
along very well and uh
and speaking uh with
that i um
after he basically essentially just sat
me down that day
that basically just kind of told me like
i shouldn't invite crazy into my life
and when he um
which we'll call it um sorry i'm getting
off top i wrote some stuff oh yeah i had
my basically alpha moment and i
basically told her like texted her like
hey my dad says you're crazy i can't
talk to you anymore see ya
[Laughter]
that's awesome yeah and uh and that was
just such a
and i look back on it so silly
and uh but i have truly applied that
situation to so many parts of my life
that it's like i now kind of judge
people if they're like like
with like going after someone who's like
suicidal or whatever like hey we have
all of our problems but there's other
people who can solve those problems and
it's just it's amazing how i've been
able to take what you say like from your
book in red flags like i was doing that
way before i even knew who the heck you
were
so yeah that is just probably the most
the first time in the story that stands
out most of my life that um
just like is like hey i'm not i can't
invite these weird people in my life
because just imagine like if i
specifically remember saying to myself
like
while trying to get with this girl like
we and for note we didn't really date or
anything it was just like a thing over
text a couple of seventh graders doing
whatever
and your games your video game buddies
um
it was like call of duty uh like first
person shooters
but yeah she uh later on down the road
she turned into quit the crazy person so
i'm glad i'm not around that
anymore but and kind of going off of
that like like i was saying i used this
uh story
with other things is like i had a friend
in junior year high school or maybe
junior senior year he was 18 and this
story is like even the red flag you know
of itself that he was a senior going
after a 15 year old eighth grader and
that was just in my opinion that's a big
red flag just because you could get put
on some i guess
list
and
i i was like this guy was just making
all these decisions i made
back then and i
was like there's there's gonna be no
saving this guy at a certain point but
yeah so basically just saying that this
story has
allowed me to assess other people's
situations very well so yeah that was
just mostly a share um
i look forward to getting in the stereo
show i got maybe another story if you
guys are willing to hear it all right so
uh save that for the stereo show then
yeah yeah yeah that's what i'm saying
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forge
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you